and welcome back everybody several
videos went viral this week showing a
mother at Miami International Airport
really losing her cool she apparently
went into panic mode after she couldn't
find her kids
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yep that woman is 25 year old Camilla
mcmilley from Alabama her two children
reportedly left their American Airlines
gates to use a nearby restroom and when
McMillan noticed they were missing
police said she became irate and
demanded that the gate agent find her
children and at one point mcmilley threw
a computer monitor at the gate age and
hitting her in the shoulder according to
the affidavit police believe mcmilley
caused over ten thousand dollars in
damage Terry mcmilley was charged with
disorderly conduct criminal mischief
aggravated battery sounds pretty serious
how serious are these charges oh these
are very serious charges I understand
her getting upset at lost kids but to do
what she did look she could be really
fined and put in jail for the first
charge for the disorderly conduct she
could get 60 days and that's a long
amount of time but for the criminal
mischief it fits over a thousand dollars
in damage and we know that it is because
we can see in these pictures that she's
doing a lot of damage there she could be
up in jail for five years and the most
difficult charge that she would have to
face is this aggravated battery she
could get 15 years for that and she
could be charged fifteen thousand
dollars so it's no small amount of money
and it's deal time and she's got kids so
jail time is not going to work too well
for her yikes well Brian you and I were
talking about this criminal charges are
not the only trouble she faces right
yeah she could get banned from that
Airline American Airline for not getting
on the flight anymore but also there's
actually a bill in the house right now
called the protection from abusive uh
passenger act just for this reason and
that act if it is passed and goes all
the way up and it doesn't seem like it's
going to get stopped if you're convicted
of a crime of assaulting or abusing or
harming anyone and working in the
airline you could actually be added to
the no-fly list banned from flying
anywhere in or out of America the United
States of America so it's not just
criminal charges she could face if this
bill passes she and other people can
find themselves on the no-fly list us
and that's very very difficult to come
off of no matter how you wanted to or
how you try it yeah that's not great um
and not to make light of the situation
but I read up on this and apparently
somebody who was there said I've seen
worse it's Miami take that for what you
will because that was pretty bad to say
the least but when a situation
developing well coming up on Long crime
daily fans expecting to see an actress
that they love in a recent movie realize
she never actually appears in the film
what a judge had to say about a lawsuit
against Universal Studios a federal
judge says a lawsuit against Universal
Studios can move forward over
allegations that one of their movie
trailers is misleading so in this clip
that you're about to see this is the
trailer for the movie yesterday which
came out in 2019 take a look
we would like him to write something
right now
something in the way
she moved no one's ever written this
many great songs how do you do it tracks
me like no other lover okay did you
catch that because in the trailer
actress Anna De armas plays a love
interest of the main character who's
suddenly the only person in the world
who knows about the Beatles and their
songs it's actually a great movie but
anyway fans filed a lawsuit saying that
they watched the movie to cedarmus and
she had been cut from the film entirely
Universal Studios wanted to throw out
the lawsuit saying they're protected
under the First Amendment but the judge
said the entire point of the trailer is
to Showcase stars and plot points the
class action lawsuit can now move
forward with the plaintiffs he can get
this 5 million dollars Terry do you
think these plaintiffs have standing to
Sue and what exactly would that mean
well for that you would have to make
sure there's an injury in fact so the
injury has to be real it can be
Financial it can be emotional here it's
the 3.99 or whatever it was then you
have to have that causal connection
meaning that the defendant caused the
injury and here you know I suppose You
could argue that it was misleading and
that they spent money and they shouldn't
have spent money but then the injury and
the connection has to also at the end of
the day be something the judge can
redress meaning that he can make amends
and make all of the parties back to
whole so he'd have to make sure that all
of these individuals got their 3.99 no
more no less unless for some reason they
were injured in a larger amount and of
course if this is a class action it's a
large amount but frankly I think that
this is pushing it
Brian here's what I don't understand
Terry said 399 movie rental turns into a
5 million dollar lawsuit they're gonna
win all that money come on I was on your
side I thought the same thing as Terry
they can't have standings doesn't make
sense there could not be cases like this
but then I researched this one case
Lady Godiva got soon for putting Belgium
1926 on their chocolates and so when
people bought them thinking that
chocolate came from Belgium instead of
Pennsylvania they filed a lawsuit and
got 15 million dollars if you filed
earlier this year you could have gone up
to 25 in that class action suit from
that 15 million that Godiva had to spend
because they put Belgium 1926 on it so
as crazy as this case may seem
they may actually win I could have won a
lot of money in my lonely Valentine's
Day eating boxes of chocolates thanks
for telling me this now Brian maybe I'll
go Sue over movie trailers you know
because I've been misled before I'll
tell you that much Terry Brian thank you
so much everyone out there thank you so
much for joining us here on Long crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss Justice in America